ja leben zerstören per mausklick wie
kann es sein dass wir ständig über
cybermobbing diskutieren ist aber immer
noch kein all die check in den sozialen
medien gibt wir brauchen eine
verifizierung wie bei einer kreditkarte
damit ist gar kein raum mehr filme oder
anonyme accounts gibt ich plädiere
darauf dass es mehr transparenz im netz
gibt und eine schnellere und härtere
strafverfolgung
ja ich bin
super das thema aufbringen weil ich muss
sagen mich schockiert dass manchmal muss
glaube ich sagen fast noch twitter ist
einer der der progressivsten kanäle ich
weiß nicht wie das mal nehmen bei
linkedin zum beispiel hat man ja ein
profil was verifiziert ist und warum
kann man gar nicht eingreifen also ich
glaube auch das wäre einfach gut weil es
gibt auch diese ganzen mit witzigen
videos wohl wie die leute sich auf
social video anschauen so hat sich im
echten leben sehen da würde ich ja nie
zu dir sagen bis jetzt und wie irgendwas
was ich hier ganz wiederholen das würden
wir das nur das ist ja gar nicht so aber
leider weil man eben ohne identität da
unterwegs ist haben die leute wirklich
aus ihrem frust und vielleicht auch
mancher mit alkohol oder so dinge raus
die auch nicht mehr lustig sind irgendwo
mit einer halt irgendwie wirklich
schlimme dinge vorwirft und ich bin
finde das eine tolle tolle initiative
würde mir auch wirklich interessieren
auch mal das feedback hier
wahrscheinlich werden auch leute von von
twitter zum beispiel oder instagram auch
zu schauen auch finde ich super warum
macht ihr das nicht warum sagt wenn ich
einfach der count der muss da muss man
sich verifizieren da muss man ein bild
hinterlegen das kann auch leicht
angekündet sein was ungefähr wiedergibt
wenn man ist weil ansonsten haben wir da
irgendwelche welche wilden dinger und
jeder kann jedem alles unterstellen ich
finde dass es ja einfach ein falscher
weg und ich würde mich freuen wenn man
da mehr vertrauen denn auch für social
media generieren den guten foto hürde
wäre viel größer gerade was cybermobbing
angeht weil ich glaube dass ganz viele
video gesagt habe ein sehr sehr großes
selbstbewusstsein haben und sich hinter
seiner maske verstecken können hinter
irgendeinem pseudonymen das überhaupt
keiner kennt aber wenn du wirklich aller
kreditkarte so ein agent verfahren
machen muss wurde in die kamera lächelt
mit der kredit also mit mit deinem
profil dann dann ist die hütte und ihr
seht ihr noch ich will ja noch eine
überhöhung reinmachen ich glaube ja dass
die sozialen medien unsere
meinungsfreiheit zerstören auf dem weg
dahin sind weil was passiert ich hatte
ja ich hatte ja schon einen oder anderen
schützen wie man sich vorstellen kann
den sozialen netzwerken dann habe ich
zum glück menschen um mich herum gab die
gesagt er lässt sich nicht davon
beeinflussen klick ist weg sagt weiter
deine meinung das geht bei mir in der
familie die grundregel sei alles aber
bloß kein follower dementsprechend bin
ich ja mal sehr auf anti aus aber wenn
ich glaube ich jetzt nicht den
familiären rückhalt hätte dass ich immer
so erzogen wurde so kehraus sei kein
follower hätte ich glaube ich mich schon
zurückgezogen auch öffentlich meine
meinung zu sagen und das finde ich so
gefährlich durch schütz storms wird
meinung weggenommen und dass man
überlegt sich doch heute drei mal was
man sagt ich leider nicht ich sage auch
wenn manchmal das glaubst du bist aber
die meisten menschen tun das gut ich da
man muss um in den sozialen netzwerken
aktiv zu sein schon die mentale stärke
mitbringen das ist ganz richtig also wer
das nicht aushält und das mag von einer
anderen extrem verwunderlich sein auch
in den ersten tagen wochen wie auch
immer wenn es dann plötzlich mal richtig
knallt der sollte sich in der tat wieder
abmelden ich mich erinnern dass ein
bisschen so an dieses na also man
schießt einfach aus dem hinterhalt
ja ja nicht gehabt deswegen sage das ist
das andere das wenig unterstützt das
voll und ganz klar name sehe ich ganz
genauso weil das andere ist wirklich wie
in sniper durch die gegend zu gehen sich
irgendwo zu verstecken auf dem hügel und
einfach wild in die gegend zu ballern in
der hoffnung dass man irgend jemand
trifft und zwar richtig erledigt das ist
das grenzt schon fast an ja
digital sieht man sieht unterschied bei
linkedin zb ist eine ganz andere
community wird durchaus diskutiert und
auch gesagt sind die grünen sich die spd
richtig oder ist es gut jetzt zu
digitalisieren oder sollten wir mehr
faxgeräte machen das kann man ja alles
diskutieren aber ich muss sagen weil da
eben echte kaum sind hält hält eine ganz
andere diskussionskultur ergeht es keine
hänger und sagt einfach du arsch und du
also die worte ja auch ab und
wiederholen sie also wirklich auch
sachen die einem die man ihm einfach
nicht mehr sagt ja das ist schon ein
problem man sieht ja bei linkedin es
geht besser also aber es ist eine
moderne hexenjagd geboren und ich finde
das ist das problem also man hat es ja
bei dem fall boateng dem fußballspieler
und seiner freundin frau tosia gesehen
also ich meine die wurde dann irgendwann
von social media so belagert von diesen
ganzen herzen dass sie sich irgendwann
um gefahr bist du schon mal ein fall wo
du heute sagt zurückblicken das war
schon scheiße tatsächlich hatte ich das
schon mehrmals und was die justiz dann
sagt ja wir können erst ausmachen was
passiert ist aber dann ist es halt so
spät und deswegen finde ich wäre so ein
also die leute würden sich das ja gar
nicht mehr trauen ich dann sagen würde
na ja aber ich muss nur einen anruf
tätigen und ich kenne deine adresse wo
du wie du heißt und so weiter und so
fort und damit war die höhe nicht mehr
so gut glaube die wird auch einfach gar
nicht mehr machen weil genau das was
genau wenn man sich gegenüber sitzen
weiß wer es ist dann sieht man ja auch
im täglichen leben mindestens erlebt
nicht dass jetzt nicht dass irgendwann
ein supermarkt rausgeht und sagt wer
eine brille ist ja der letzte scheiß
sondern die leute haben ja ein anders an
wenn man sich selber in die augen schaut
einfach mal so ich glaube gut für die
strafverfolgung aber ich glaube es würde
auch an sich einfach schon direkt beste
eine bessere kommunikationsbasis sein
wenn jeder sagt ich bin frontal und dass
das jetzt mal meinung genau also ich
weiß jetzt nicht ob ich der ob man die
leute also man kann es dann vielleicht
melden so wie es mir hier behaupten das
bringt mir das schon oft probiert und
auch im fall kann ja wie viele willst du
denn melden oder wenn es jetzt wenn du
es unterbricht auf schulen ja wenn du
gemobbt wirst als schülerin
muss auch wieder sagen wir jeder geht ja
freiwillig in diese sozialen netzwerke
rein da ist heute drauf
aber richtig kann muss man auf auf zum
beispiel muss man als schauspieler haben
zwar ein aber wenn du hören wir meinen
es ist was da passiert und ich will gar
nicht in diese klarnamen geschichte
sprechen aber es gibt auch
spitzenpolitiker
können wir alle die sind nicht auf
twitter was ich schaue ja aber man kann
das doch auch verstehen auf der einen
seite also m3 das ergebnis das wären
also man muss es aushalten es gibt auch
spitzenpolitiker die sagen sie gehen auf
twitter und wissen was da passiert und
senden eigentlich nur botschaften das
machen sie ganz bewusst und kalkuliert
alles was kommt mit ein ich glaube aber
freiwillig ist es schon ein freiwilliger
hat also glaube es gibt bisher noch
keine verpflichtung muss auf twitter
sein ich muss dir recht aber konstruktiv
sein und ich finde das ist der
unterschied wenn es unter die
gürtellinie geht und in horden die sich
verabreden umzusetzen das ist eine ganz
andere hausnummer finden aber ich habe
meine technologische frage wir haben wir
hier den experten gehören frank und zwar
bei dem corona virus gerade egal was ich
poste wenn es auch nur in irgendeiner
form was mit corona zu tun als sei es
nur das wort im kommen denn dieser
warnhinweis corona warnhinweis auf
instagram immer sofort hier gibt's die
richtige warum gibt es nicht für mobbing
ist es noch nicht so weit die netzwerke
sind die noch nicht so weit um so ein
hinweis zu machen achtung hier passiert
mobbing das wird jetzt schon sind
währung führen ehrlich gesagt ich freue
mich dass auch weil wir selber
entwickeln auch in verschiedene
unternehmen künstliche intelligenz und
unsere ganz klare einschätzung ist dass
es wirklich in vielen vielen dingen
möglich also ich habe zum beispiel mir
aktuell bei instagram wirklich zum
bayerischen post mache kommen 20 drin
ich bin durch dich reich geworden klick
hier das ist ehrlich gesagt für eine
künstliche intelligenz trivial das zu
erkennen da frage ich mich wirklich
wollen sie das nicht wenn ein anderes
beispiel bringen berühmte leute
die tabelle am main name leider sehr
viel immer wieder auf google halt
werbung dafür klick hier und werde reich
wie frank mit bitcoins das einfach wurde
mit foto und wirklich auch übrigens auch
bild zeitung als hätte ich das in der
bild zeitung gesagt und so wirklich ganz
klar erkennbar und wir haben so oft mit
google darüber diskutiert und sagt ihr
seid so ein tolles
technologieunternehmen ihr müsst das
doch erkennen irgendwie auch hier
nochmal aufruf gerne diskussion wenn von
unternehmen her jemand zuhört mich würde
wirklich eine ganz klare stellung mal
interessieren warum kriegt ihr das nicht
hin ich glaube sie kriegen sondern ich
glaube es ist einfach was engagement
kosten würde das finde ich sehr schade
ich weiß aber dass die begründung ist
vielleicht eher nicht unterstellen ich
kann nur sagen ich glaube wir können das
nicht beurteilen und da geht deutlich
mehr solche solche solchen hass gerade
auch wenn ihr jetzt zum beispiel ich
weiß die frau oder freundin war von
einem bekannten fußballspieler hier so
massiv angegriffen wird dass man dann
noch mal er den algorithmus youtube und
sagt alles was auch möglich eventuell
negativer weise genau also dass das
hätten die schon glaube ich besser
managen können
[Musik]